yes drew barrymore is showing off her
20-pound weight loss on Tuesday the 44
year olds hit up Instagram to share some
before and after pics and she looks
freaking awesome
I just feel really lucky to keep keep on
keepin on as Bob Dylan says drew gave
props to her trainer Marni Alton
captioning the post quote she has helped
me healed me encouraged me to keep going
when I felt like being strong was an
insurmountable task according to Drew
the two have known each other for about
15 years and when the a-lister was
looking to transform her body for her
Netflix series Santa Clarita diet
it was Marni to the rescue quote Marni
was the one who got me there I lost 20
pounds and trained like a mother in 2018
drew dish to eat tea about getting in
shape for the role as a suburban human
flesh eating real estate agent I'm a
vegan and I work out and I live a
completely different lifestyle and diet
while being her because she is only
eating protein and you'd be very lean
and she's got this energy and basically
immortality now that who would not look
prettier with immortality so I think
just for me as a female and a woman and
a mom this show is a great wake-up call
for me every summer to live your best
life anyway back to her epic in stuff
its bow if you thought the love stop
there you are dead wrong drew who shares
two kids olive and Frankie with her
ex-husband will Kopelman wrote about
what a great friend Marnie was along the
way calling her one of the greats and
adding quote it's not all about being
terminators it's about how to find
yourself how to be your best self the
post is just one of many Drew has shared
in honor of wellness week don't get me
wrong girl my core before I ever met you
wasn't great anyway she kicked things
off by talking to her daughter about
celebrating our challenges as well as
our triumphs it's not like wow I had
this amazing body and then I had kids I
never was strong in my core and pelvic
floor she shared this workout in the gym
[Applause]
a sweat sesh at home working out at home
it's also good for indoor pet and this
moment from the yoga studio stillness if
it's powerful and stop provoking and
emotionally compelling is hurling
yourself around throwing yourself to
music working out your anger working
through things being quiet and still can
bring some of the most powerful things
to our bodies of anything else
I want to promote being a long long long
time
yogi drew you are an inspiration and you
look freaking great way to go girl of
course et will be here to bring you all
the latest on drew so make sure to keep
it locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens see you soon
[Music]